47 étudiants se sont rassemblés pendant
cinq jours pour la troisième édition de
l'innovation se meurt quand de
l'université paris saclay lui projet
était centrée sur la problématique des
nouvelles mobilités les idées ne
manquaient pas dans le hall de l'estaca
quelques heures avant le verdict du jury
c'est une application pour faciliter le
transport en commun dans la ville et
donner un côté plus sociale au transport
en commun
c'est super intense mais ça fonctionne
c'est génial c'est une méthode vraiment
qui vient d'arriver en france
c'est un des premiers stages qui fait en
france aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
produire en une semaine c'est incroyable
des cabines et pourra mettre des mois
pour le faire et c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire ça décuple les capacités
de chacun dans notre équipe il y as de
l'informatique du design de la pharmacie
de l'agroalimentaire de l'économie de
six personnes on aurait rencontré dans
notre événement et c'est ça qui permet
de créer des solutions qui sont
intéressantes parce qu'on a une approche
et les visions des choses qui est
différent dans l'amphithéâtre de l'école
d'ingénieurs les noms des lauréats sont
dévoilés prix du public et coup de coeur
du jury sont décernés au même projet st
bernard qui prévoit d'aider les
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer à se
déplacer à rentrer chez elle
grand gagnant de cette édition opine
applications pour faciliter le transport
en commun le rendant plus agréable du
coup maintenant falloir se pencher sur
la question après qu'est ce qu'on fait
on est une équipe de six donc on vient
de gagner un prix le but c'est quand
même de continuer le projet de monter
donc voilà
ouais se pencher sur ce qu'on fait avec
ce projet est ce qu'on va pouvoir voir
en faire une récompense permettant de
continuer cette dynamique
entrepreneuriale le concept du groupe
opi pourra bénéficier d'une dotation de
3000 euros pour lancer sa propre start
up